así es que tú eres yo y estamos en
clases de matemáticas dibujando flores y
pétalos si quieres algo con un montón de
pétalos seguro estás siguiendo alguna
regla que dice así agregan nuevos
pétalos en los espacios entre los
pétalos que ya están ahí puedes hacer
eso de forma muy precisa empieza con
cierta cantidad de pétalos digamos 5
luego agrega otra capa en medio así es
que tienes que agregar 10 y luego 20 la
parte inconveniente de esta regla es que
tienes que terminar cada capa para que
no se vea incompleto la regla ideal te
permitiría agregar pétalos hasta que te
aburrirás ahora imagina que eres una
planta y que quieres crecer extendiendo
tus hojas de tal forma que cachés la
mayor cantidad de luz solar
desafortunadamente y espero no estar
suponiendo demasiado pero siendo una
planta pues no eres muy inteligente no
sabes cómo sumar números para crear una
serie no sabes geometría y proporciones
no puedes dibujar espirales o
rectángulos o gato babosas
o tal vez si puedes seguir una regla
simple los botánicos han observado que
las plantas son muy consistentes con
respecto al ángulo entre una hoja y la
siguiente veamos lo que puedes hacer con
eso así es que crece tu primera hoja y
si no cambiaste el ángulo la siguiente
hoja crece directamente arriba y eso no
es nada bueno porque te tapa la luz del
sol puede rotar 180 grados para tener la
siguiente hoja del lado opuesto lo cual
parece ideal excepto porque si vuelves a
rotar 180 grados
la tercera hoja termina justo arriba de
la primera de hecho en cualquier
fracción de un círculo con un entero en
el denominador ese entero es el número
de hojas que podemos poner sin que se
traslapan después de esas todas se
traslapan completamente y a diferencia
de cuando dibujas siendo una planta no
eres suficientemente inteligente como
para ver que ya diste toda una vuelta y
que ya deberías agregar hojas en medio
si estás tratando de posponer el
traslape haciendo la fracción muy
pequeña solo obtienes un montón de
traslape
y desperdicias todo este espacio lo cual
es completamente desastroso pero tal vez
otras fracciones son buenas como las que
acomodan las hojas con un patrón estilo
estrella se va a tardar bastante antes
de trasladarse y las hojas estarán bien
distribuidas mientras tanto pero qué tal
que hay una proporción que nunca se
traslapa por completo para cualquier
fracción racional la estrella se cierra
eventualmente pero qué tal que usamos un
número irracional el tipo de número que
no se puede expresar como la división de
dos números enteros qué tal si usamos el
número más irracional de todos si
piensas que eso suena muy raro decir que
un número irracional es más irracional
que otro tal vez te gustaría estudiar
teoría de números si estudias teoría de
números tal vez nos digas que fi es el
número más irracional o tal vez digas
que esto sería como decir que el 1 es el
más entero de los números enteros o
digas que no estás de acuerdo con nada
de eso en fin si es mayor que 1 pero
menor que 2
porque tres medios pero menor que cinco
tercios mayor que ocho quintos pero
trece octavos es demasiado grande y
21-13 a vos es un poquito pequeño 34 21
nuevos están más cerca pero es muy
grande y así cada par de números de
fibonacci adyacentes forman una fracción
que se acerca cada vez más y más así
conforme tomamos números más grandes
esos son los mismos números que miden
los lados de estos cuadrados ahora deja
de estudiar teoría de números y regresa
a hacer una planta pones tu primera hoja
en algún lugar y luego la segunda hoja
haciendo un ángulo de una décima parte
del círculo que dependiendo de si vas
hacia un lado o hacia el otro puede ser
como 200 22.52 o como 137.5 excelente tu
segunda hoja está bastante lejos de la
primera y tiene mucho espacio para tomar
el sol y agregamos otra hoja a una
distancia de una fina parte del círculo
y otra vez y otra vez puedes ver que las
hojas nuevas suelen crecer en espacios
que aparecen entre las hojas anteriores
nunca llenan el espacio por completo así
es que siempre hay espacio suficiente
para una hoja más sin tener que hacer
toda una capa más es muy práctico y
siendo una planta seguro te encanta esto
también es una buena forma de darle
suficiente espacio a las semillas ya los
pétalos si eres una planta que sigue
este esquema tienes mucha ventaja pero
de dónde salen las espirales dibujemos
un cono de pino de la misma forma
por cierto puedes hacer tu propio angula
tron de fibra 2 doblando una esquina de
tu cuaderno si lo dobla este así tienes
45 y 90 grados que es 135 casi 130 y 7.5
grados con mucho cuidado puedes agregar
unos cuantos grados más arranca tu
angulación y listo
agrega una nueva semilla de pino kadhafi
grados cada vez más grandes y lejos
puedes marcar las distancias con tu
ángulo tron y observa las espirales se
forman solitas y si contamos el número
de brazos mira es 5
y 8 si te preguntas por qué se forman
espirales y por qué siempre con números
de fibonacci puedes transformarte otra
vez en un geómetra o matemático o algo
así pero veamos las cosas intuitivamente
una forma simple para dibujar flores es
empezar con cierto número de pétalos por
ejemplo 5 y en la segunda vuelta agregar
la siguiente capa de pétalos muy cerca
de la primera pero más grandes cada capa
agrega 5 pétalos y se forman 5 brazos en
espiral ahora regresa aquí hay tres
pétalos en la primera vuelta y si son
muy anchos en la segunda capa agrega
tres pétalos que se traslapan un poco
con los primeros y así se sigue aunque
si empezará con pétalos más delgados la
segunda vuelta no se traslapa tanto
puedes poner ocho pétalos antes de que
se forme la segunda capa y se traslapan
lo suficiente como para que se vean las
espirales así es que esta vez tenemos 8
y 13 bueno de hecho ninguna de las
espirales están físicamente ahí en
ninguna de estas plantas simplemente los
pétalos están
siente mente cerca como para que veas
este patrón entonces lo único que tiene
que hacer la planta para tener esos
increíbles números de fibonacci de
espirales es agregar hojas o pétalos con
un ángulo de 130 y 7.5 grados el resto
se acomoda solo el hecho de que la serie
de fibonacci esté en tantas cosas en
realidad dice menos acerca de esas cosas
y más acerca de matemáticas a eso se
dedican las matemáticas reglas simples
con secuencias complejas un proceso tan
simple que hasta lo puede hacer una
planta provoca estas estructuras
increíbles a nuestro alrededor al igual
que unos cuantos postulados pueden
darnos una geometría super poderosa
aunque esto es suponiendo que las
plantas si pueden hacerlo pero eso de
medir ángulos entre las hojas puedes ver
que definitivamente si lo hacen no es
como que tengan un ambulatorio pero las
plantas han existido un buen rato y han
tenido muchísima práctica y es
probablemente lo explica todo y por eso
siempre obtenemos cinco y ocho espirales
en esta flor 5 y 8 en la alcachofa 5 y 8
en el cono de semillas de pino y hasta
este brócoli tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y en
fin siempre obtenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
y 1 2 3 4 sería muy fácil clasificar a
todos éstos como mutantes anómalos pero
sólo porque son distintos e inusuales no
es necesario ignorar los 4 7 11 que
podrían significar estos números tal vez
las cosas no son tan sencillas como yo
pensaba